self-improvement is the answer to
whatever obstacle is staring you in the
face right now the only difference
between you and greatness is the
willingness to grow and improve it's not
Talent it's not smarts it's the
willingness to improve yourself the
difference between you and Tony Robbins
is he has spent more time constantly
improving himself than most people on
the planet here's a guy who had multiple
fathers growing up had an abusive mother
who at 17 he had to run away from home
so he could become a janitor and never
go to college he then decided to be a
success he read 700 books in 7 years he
studied under mentors like Jim ran and
today he's the founder or owner of
companies with over $6 billion dollar in
annual revenue if Tony Robbins can go
from being an abused janitor with no
college education to being one of the
most influential people in the world why
can't you